okay so let's go
[Music]
okay so we got felix bernas 1672 who
plays the scandi
now you guys already know that in the
scandi it's standard routine to attack
the queen
and if the queen goes to a5 which is the
main line we go d4 occupying the center
bishop f5 is the main line we simply
develop our pieces
and knight c6 which is a a move that
we've encountered in a slightly
different version
now we already know if you guys were
attentive yesterday the purpose of this
move
is to apply pressure on the d4 pawn so
from a logical perspective where can we
develop this bishop to neutralize the
knight
yeah bishop b5 also remember that if he
castles long
he's liable to get his pawn structure
completely ruined with bishop takes c6
so this is a good example of dynamic
development we tailor our development
uh based on what our opponent does
rather than kind of put our head down
and develop
our pieces to squares that just look
nice regardless normally if black plays
c6 here
the bishop would come out to c4 but
specifically here it's a good idea to
come up to b5
okay so already black is in trouble
actually this is a bad move
and yeah and a move like bishop d7 with
a singular jupiter would signal to us
that
it's time to punish him for this so how
can we apply
some heat add some tabasco sauce to the
position
how do we add some tobasco sauce to the
position yeah absolutely we can go d5
and this is justified because we've got
three pieces developed
he's got only two his king side is
undeveloped and his queen is kind of
stuck
in mud here so whoa knight 65 pre-move
so he's got to go knight b8 otherwise
we're going to take
his b yeah so okay
now let's figure out what we should do
here now uh we can take his bishop but
then we help him right we help him
redevelop his knight which doesn't make
much sense
the great thing about where his bishop
is right now is that it's actually going
to stop his knight from coming out to a
good square
so the correct move in my opinion here
would be something that a lot of people
would struggle to play
and as i've said before people just
people struggle to play retreating moves
but retreating moves can be
absolutely desp are absolutely
indispensable so let's just drop our
bishop back
to c4 or d3 i like bishop c4 because it
keeps the d5 pawn nice and protected
if we'd gone bishop d3 maybe he would
have developed his knight to f6 and
attacked the pawn
so he goes queen c5 now instead of just
meekly dropping the bishop back we can
ask ourselves can we perhaps defend this
bishop
and make a useful move toward our
development and we actually can we can
go queen e2
that x-rays his king we prepare bishop
e3 and long castle
and we defend the bishop on c4 so the
move yeah so let's go bishop e3
attacking the queen with tempo
and then basically against any move
we're going to complete our development
by castling and now we are ready
to move in for the kill because he's
he's not going to have enough time to
complete his development just watch
um let's see what he does my guess is
that he's going to probably play g6 no
knight a6
so what does he want with this move he
probably wants to castle long
and the first possible possibility of
course is to take on a6 but
you know i'm not sure that it's worth
taking this pawn because it opens up the
b
file for him and he can perhaps mount
some counter play against
against our arcane so we got to ask
ourselves instead how do we prevent him
from castling here is there a inactive
move that prevents him from castling and
i'm looking
for a subtle prophylactic move a nice
prophylactic move that's also an active
move
regardless of the fact that it's
prophylactic very good guys the move is
95.
if he castles we can either play bishop
takes a6 crushing him
or knight takes f7 crushing him
so when you're stopping your opponent's
threats you want to also make sure that
you're
you're doing it in a way that's not like
you're not going out of your way
okay so choose your poison let's
actually just do this first
for the sake of simplicity now queen
takes a6 is very tempting
uh but it actually meets with bishop to
b queen to b7
so uh i wouldn't burn that bridge just
yet let's play knight takes f7 first
let's see
how he plays if he goes rook g8 see now
ladies and gentlemen
if we play knight takes d8 at least he
gets an exchange for the queen
so we play queen takes a6 so that after
he goes queen b7 we can take his queen
but the point is not to trade queens the
point is that we are able to take the
entire rook
and then evacuate our night and the game
is over does that make sense
and look at this pawn also freezing his
development entirely
he's to try to fianchetto but i mean
doesn't matter what we do here it's just
over
uh we can do a bunch of different things
let's uh let's play it
simple let's just double rooks on this
open file
and uh win the game man i'm feeling
pumped after that match
good day good day so he wants to get his
knight to d6
and um you know i i call this a gate
move
it's like he tries to close the gate and
we got to get this rook to a good square
before he closes the gate what do i mean
by that where can we put this rock
where can we put this rook no but
the gate okay the gate is closed along
the default of course we can go rook a4
we can go like this
but i call this slipping through the
gate
right we've slipped through the gate now
the knight on d6 doesn't bother us
because this rook on d7 combines with
the knight
to cause tremendous harm to black's king
in black's pawn
okay so this is just winning
okay c6 of course here we can just play
knight takes e7 check
that's the simplest all points are
refunded yes
and uh that's it we will bring our other
rook into the game as we like to do
okay let's just trade and go rook d1 and
promote this pawn on e6 just go e7
rook d8 and win the game we can actually
just remove it
knight d6 i'll take the knight and then
promote
all right my friend i think it's time to
resign
what do you think you are andrew tang
yes good
so nice
yeah so basically a very simple game
uh we developed our pieces he played
knight c6 which is a very poor move
bishop b5 is the key
d5 basically closing him in and then the
glue move was bishop c4
see this move is what people really
struggle to play
at the approximate 1600 level because it
it
you know you associate retreating moves
with something bad right a retreating
move means that something has gone wrong
but that absolutely is false and you can
see that it's a retreating move in name
only because
we are basically leaving him unable to
develop his
queen side pieces in any adequate way
and not to mention the fact that he
hasn't developed his king's side
chess.com refunds the point so queen e2
to defend the bishop now
i want people to understand why the move
b3 is not good
can somebody explain to me conceptually
why b3
is not good now in this specific
position it's fine
but but there is a specific concept here
that i want everybody to
fully understand
okay so exactly you're leaving your
knight on c3
undefended uh and
that's a very dangerous thing to do okay
and black can go b5
and he can try to dislodge the bishop
and win the knight be very careful about
leaving your pieces
undefended on squares where they're
accessible to your opponent's pieces
a queen to d4 uh beast slayer would not
be good because it trades queens and
here in this position you want to
preserve the queens
in order to be able to attack why would
you want to attack because you're
ahead in development the rest was very
straightforward
literally just taking all of his pieces
okay next game
this was very simple
yeah i won the bullet match
ralph saad let's go e4 again and he
plays a
okay e6 c6 now we already know this is
weird
uh we're not going to change our
strategy based on weird moves that try
to intimidate us
okay so he plays kind of a cross between
a french and a chiropractor not a great
idea because it's just very passive
uh now should we play e5 here what do
you guys think
should we play e5
some people say yes we can
but it's actually not a good idea it's
actually not a great move
and after the game i will explain in
detail
the two reasons and i'm just writing all
this down sorry
why it's not a great move should we take
on d5
definitely not because that allows him
to recapture and vacates
the natural development square for the
knights we're going to do nothing and he
takes
great look at how nice our knights are
where should we put this bishop
should we put it on c4 what do you guys
think
d3 absolutely we shouldn't put it on c4
then it would be biting at granite
knight f6 now we can take the knight we
can also not take the knight it doesn't
really matter
we can drop the knight to g3 or we could
support it with queen e2 there's a lot
of ways to do this
let's play it very simple just take it
and um how should we solidify this pawn
what would be the best way of
solidifying this part i remember the key
principle which i always share which is
that uh you want the piece of least
value
to do a particular task so you have a
choice between bishop e3 and c3
which be should you delegate the task of
defending upon it certainly we should be
the pawn building up a nice pawn chain
now black's bishop is very weak now i
want to introduce you guys
to a version of the greek gift sacrifice
which
a lot of people are not aware of now the
greek gift sacrifice i won't talk about
at length in the interest of time
but you guys can see the elements of the
greek gift in action
what is the problem here why can't we
take on h7 and go knight g5 obviously
black has a bishop that controls the
square
so what can we do to take the g5 square
under control first
in preparation for the great gift
sacrifice
and this is a attacking technique that
everybody should be familiar with
h4 let's see if he can let's see if he
actually spots
nope beautiful guys this is our first
greek gift sacrifice
bishop takes h7
and i'm going to do some interesting
research after the game knight g5 now
what was the purpose of h4
if he takes on g5 what are we going to
take with
of course we're going to take with a
pawn now you guys might be like whoa
whoa but but he's taking our knight what
are we gonna attack with well if you
look
if he would have taken we would have
taken with a pawn and then the queen
would have combined with a rook
to deliver decisive threats down the h
file
we have checkmate in three moves here
or like four moves something like that
three moves we have
we have two choices we can go h5 and we
can send the king onto a square where it
can be discovered by the knight
but even better is to go queen to d3 uh
because if he goes king h6 we don't even
need to deliver a discovered check we
can simply checkmate him on h7
now he goes king h5 we need to reason
logically
if we can find a way to send his king
back to h6
then we will have queen h7 checkmate but
if we can find a way to send his king
forward let's say to g4
then we're gonna have queen f3 checkmate
of course the move is g4
and he's damned if he does and damned if
he doesn't
and it's checkmate this is a very
classic greek gift attack
okay so h4 was the key move
right it sets up the g5 square
now i actually was going to research who
was the first ever person to actually
come up with a great gift sacrifice
so according to my research the first
person and let me let me do a little
search on megabase
the first person to have actually played
a greek of sacrifice
in an actual game
let me see
graco g aquino graco
1620 i think graco invented the greek
gift sacrifice now
where can we check this information
classical era modern chess
let's see if he talks about it who
invented the gree gift sacrifice
or the trojan [ __ ] sacrifice
yeah it's not um but it looks like
gioquino graco who is a 17th century
italian chess player who wrote
several manuscripts where he analyzed a
bunch of openings and among them
he came up with agree gift sacrifice um
now a couple of you might ask
a couple of you might ask yeah let's
change the title
um
speed run
yes now um
a couple of you might ask after h4 now
let's say that black sniffs this out and
goes h6
can anybody propose now a um
a way that we can start to develop the
attack on the king side there's actually
two possible moves
and then we'll dial it back and i'll
explain why not e5 in the opening
so knight g5 is possible but he can
actually not take the knight
he'll just ignore the knight so the
first is to attack with a pawn
now the pawn on h6 is what's called a
hook a hoke is a pawn
that has moved from its original spot
and is located near the king a hook can
be used by your pawns or by your pieces
to open up the king side easy in an
easier way
and you can do that by simply advancing
to g5
okay uh so that's number one
number two is called building a battery
and you can do that by playing bishop c2
followed by queen to d3
now why is the inclusion of h4h6 in
white's favor
watch let's say that black develops his
knight and you go queen d3
you're threatening checkmate on h7 black
is only one plausible way to defend
against this which is what
well black technically has two ways but
really only one way to stop the queen
from coming to
h7 that is the move g6 but here's the
thing
look at this pawn very carefully guys we
can capture it
not only can we capture that pawn we can
use the h-bond as a battering ram
and shatter the other palm black loses
and if you compare that to the immediate
bishop c2
then after g6 it is true that you can
play h4 now and you can try to use the
same pawn as the same battering ram
the pawn on g6 is a lot better protected
so
h4 is good not only because it sets up
the greek gift sacrifice but even if
it is stopped black must make
concessions on his king side
which you can then use by building a
battery
and if i were actually playing black
here how would what would i do
um black's position is already very bad
but i would probably let me think
hmm yeah no this position is uh very
very bad for like maybe g6 i don't know
no black's position is extremely
difficult folks there is one thing you
can try there's a trap you can set
you can try to go queen to d5 and what
is the purpose of this move
let's imagine the y now takes on h7
plays knight g5
king g8 and how is the uh the greek gift
usually followed up in this position
obviously green h5
and why did i put a queen on d5 can
anybody tell me what is the purpose of
queen d5 what move does black now have
this is often missed
in greek gift sacrifices the fact that
you can actually defend
the square on h7 you can play queen to
f5 and then black screen comes around to
g6
and the attack evaporates so that's
actually a way that you can defend
against the great gift
you can allow the knight to get to g5
and the queen to h5
and then you can either place a bishop
on this diagonal or a queen
and defend the h7 pawn okay hopefully
that makes sense
now the only thing i wanted to point out
here is why the movie five is bad
it's not that it's bad it's just that
black has already spent three moves
moving his pawns
so from a purely logical perspective we
want to keep the center as open as
possible
and e5 closes it up which lessens the
impact
of black making crappy moves in the
opening the second thing
that um that i want you guys to notice
is this this is a pawn chain
do does black usually well not just
black but
uh when when your opponent is a pawn
chain do you want to attack the tip of
the pawn chain or the base of the pawn
chain usually
by nimzovich's principle now not always
but
generally the base now what can you tell
me about the can black attack the base
of the pawn chain
can black attack the base of the pawn
chain and if so how
yes with c5 and here is the problem
in such positions white wants to be able
to play c3 in order to defend the base
of the pawn chain here believe it or not
the knight on c3 as natural as it looks
actually obstructs the pawn from coming
to c3
which means that white's pawn chain
collapses
not a disaster right you can take big
deal but
you know now the pawn on e5 is weak and
now black has good development for his
pieces
so in positions where you have this kind
of pawn chain with a pawn on e5 and upon
d4
you usually want to make sure that you
can play c3
in the event that black plays c5 okay
but that's not
that's a secondary thing the primary
thing is that i want to keep the center
as open as possible uh so remember
you don't always have to react to some
sort of move by your opponent you can
just continue developing
you can do nothing okay
uh and hopefully that makes sense guys
we took c3 to defend the pawn
and h4 to set up the greek gift
sacrifice
okay ready for the next game guys
let's go m d
bar mbdar let's go with a sitilian
let's go with an accelerated dragon okay
so he goes c4
which is a move it's a rare move what is
the prop what is the uh drawback of this
move
what is the drawback of this move
it's 2 am d4 is weak
let's go knight c6 how should we develop
our pieces to
maximally emphasize our control and
cement rather our control over the d4
score where should this bishop
go should it go on um on e7 or
should it go somewhere else
so d6 e5 ladies and gentlemen would be
counterproductive because it would
weaken our own d5 square you want to
make sure that
you're not overdoing this right if you
go e5 you create a symmetrical weakness
on d5
and so we simply want a fiance with a
bishop
we can basically pre-move it he's
probably not going to go d4 and blender
the pawn
exactly now
we go bishop g7 then we're going to go
d6 and we can go knight f6 another way
of playing here would be e6 knight ge7
that's the botvinic setup
but i think it's simpler to just go d6
preparing to develop the bishop now
here's a question from a purely
positional standpoint
what do we want to do here in in terms
of again
uh in enhancing our dominance over the
d4 score you guys have seen this idea
before many times
in various types of positions what
should be our plan here
our next two moves pin the knight
and then what do we do and then take
take the knight because now we enhance
our control over d4
now do we want to go knight d4 quite yet
no we do not
we can but the threat is stronger than
the execution there's no point in
rushing
the move knight t4 let's wait for a
better moment let's complete our
development
how should we complete our development
uh i don't
love knight f6 as much because it
interferes
it interferes with our control
over the d4 square does that make sense
if we go knight f6 he can actually try
to go d4
and absolve himself of that weakness so
we should think about where
else we should put this knight before we
go queen b6 and delegate our queen
the task of sort of artificially
controlling d4
we should ask ourselves if the knight
may have alternate accommodations made
for it and it can
e6 knight g7 some of you might be
looking at this and saying
wait that's two moves right isn't it
good to develop in one move well yes but
look at how passive white's pieces are
you can afford to take the luxury of
spending two moves if it means that you
you know you do something as important
as keep control over this square okay
it goes b3 now how should we proceed
uh in this position well i think we've
completed our development
the time has come for us to put a knight
on t4 where can this knight on e7 go
later i mean on the next move basically
where can it go
bingo bingo it can go to c6
and it can it can support its brother
over on d4
look at this beautiful look at these
stallions ladies and gentlemen
these are some stallions now he's
probably gonna go f4 which is the
correct idea that is white's only source
of active counter play
let's see what he does how should we
stop
the move f5 let's stop f5 i don't want
it i don't want to allow it
no you don't no no no not on my watch
not on my watch give him the
kemba mutombo not on our watch
now literally not on my watch so how
should we proceed
in this position and this is where a lot
of people struggle uh it seems like
we've made all the necessary
improvements
but now we need to continue applying
pressure
there are several ways of doing that the
first question we should ask ourselves
is are there any pieces
which can be activated and certainly
there are
if we look at our queen our queen is not
doing anything let's employ the queen
let's give it a nice little job
and its job is going to be to add
pressure on the knight
and add pressure on the a2 pawn then we
can look at the rook on aid and say this
rook is not doing anything we can bring
it to a more
civilized square on e8 where it's at
least in the center
okay queen h4 i will explain after the
game
why it's not good although queen h4
actually is kind of is totally fine also
yeah queen h4 is perfectly good
uh and uh some of you might be thinking
but wait a second
isn't it a bad idea to bring the queen
away from our king side white is not
attacking the king's side
so this is fine um
actually somebody put forward a really
interesting idea
what about a queen side attack let's
make a queen side attack happen how can
we do that
in order to get a queen-side attack
going we have to chip away
at his pawn chain we have to find a way
to you know
add some salt and pepper to this
position so we need to go b5
but let's not go b5 immediately let's
prepare it by playing a6 so that if he
takes we can recapture with the fun
and open up that a file then we justify
the fact that we haven't moved the rook
ah a4 perfect we got him
we got him and of course the piece that
wins the game
is precisely the knight on d4 boom goes
to dynamite
knight takes you one and here's the
funny thing the other knight is then
going to come to d4
but i have the most in your oh okay
thank you for the knight he should have
taken with a rook
okay g takes f5 taking tour of the
center
now let's defend the pawn
now i want you guys to tell me the most
like in your face positional move ever
we shouldn't go knight d4 there is a
slightly more subtle move here
bishop d4 get rid of this bishop so then
we have an eternal knight on d4
exactly and let's not forget our initial
intention was to play p5
he rudely interrupted us by blundering a
rook but that doesn't mean
we still don't have the idea of going p5
that that hasn't gone anywhere we're
going to go p5
we damn well we're going to go b5
because now we're off a rook
there we go so not only did we complete
our plan we want to rook on the way
and the game is over so rude
okay obviously trading rooks here is
perfectly good for us
if he doesn't trade we're going to
infiltrate we're going to threaten
checkmate and we're going to attack the
bishop
and let's see if we can deliver a cool
checkmate let's bring the other rook
into the game
and i'm going to show you guys a very
typical checkmating idea
basically our plan is going to be to
make him resign
which he did okay great game
now again here a couple of you were very
quick to say that we should play e5 to
increase our control over the square but
be careful
because this creates a symmetrical
weakness on d4
now here we play bishop g4 bishop takes
f3 right
that's what i call the smith's love idea
vasily smith love the former world
champion from the soviet union had a
very famous game
which is shown to all all russian
young chats players where he does
exactly this he goes like bishop g5
takes f6 and then he puts a knight on d5
i even showed you guys uh
a couple of those examples yesterday
great stream thank you lily
and uh this was actually a pivotal
moment where we played e6
right um so i just wanted to make sense
to everybody why knight f6
is not quite as good now the smith's
love game i've already showed
but if you guys want to see the the
segment that i'm referring to
uh here it is sure of course i can
always
show so this is the smith's love game
you see smith
rutakovsky championship final moscow
1945.
so to test my hypothesis
let's see if this book is featured in do
i have a book
that teaches young soviet children how
to play chess i do
my favorite book this is from 1952 this
is a
basically a complete manual of chess
let me see if it's in the book short
game smith's love is in the book
but not against rutakovsky so here it's
not but anyways it's a very famous game
so this is liz sidson's book uh what
should uh what should y do here ladies
and gentlemen
yep bishop g5 boom boom
boom that's it got a knight to d5
now by the way queen takes c2 here uh
there's a tactical reason why this is
not possible because basically
you force the queen off of the c file
and then you give a fork
uh so smithslav gets the 995. so that's
why i call this the smithslav idea
okay and we do exactly the same thing
here just
wearing different clothes right bishop
g4 bishop f3 this is how pattern
recognition works
now we get to get a knight to d4 the
other knight comes to its aid
f5 to stop his ideas queen a5 to employ
the queen
a6 to prepare a pawn breaker which he
prevents forgetting that he's weak in
the b3 square now we literally take
everything
complete our plan get the rook to the
second get the other rook into the game
he resigns
um okay any
questions about this game
could you discuss queen h4 instead yeah
so queen h4 would also have been
possible
um now i would be a little bit hesitant
about putting it on h4 because it's
right in the middle of a lot of white
pieces
and you've got to be a little bit
careful about that you know bishop f2
might become possible although
it is true that you can take the pawn
i'm just not sure how this can be
followed up
the queen alone is not going to really
create that many chances here and i'm
not sure exactly how you can follow this
up
uh can i show the mate i talked about
sure so let's say he does this
basically the mate i talked about
nothing extraordinary black to play in
this position
black to play in this position
very simple
so rookie two yeah rookie two and rook
takes c2
and uh knight both defends the rokin and
takes away the only
only possible retreat square okay
so that's the entire idea i was going to
show uh very important
continue to look for mating nets even in
the end game do not forget to do that
after knight d4 bishop takes do we take
with the bishop asks
malcolm tucker yes malcolm so basically
we of course we take with the bishop
nimzovich makes the rather gruesome
analogy to a dentist
right a weak square he says is like a
cavity
and the reason you don't usually take
back with pawns in such situations is
because that's like
voluntarily taking your opponent to the
dentist and
and paying for his cavity being filled
pawns aren't very good at occupying weak
squares because they don't really do
anything it's exactly like a dental
filling
according to the nymphs i didn't invent
this analogy now bishop takes d4 you
guys might be like wait a second
didn't we want a knight on d4 well yes
but eventually we're going to get a
knight on d4 and the bishop is the next
best thing the bishop is beautiful here
as well
does that make sense now
do i am i saying that it's always a bad
idea to recapture with a pawn
that a pawn is always bad at occupying
weak squares
absolutely not i can give you guys many
exceptions to the rules sometimes for
example
uh you know you take back with a pawn
and you vacate
or or you cement your control over
another weak square you know
there's exceptions but basically this is
a quite a firm rule when you have a weak
square
you want to make sure that pieces occupy
that square not months